hey 42 here scientists calculated that
Santa would have to visit 822 homes per
second to deliver all the world's
presents on Christmas Eve traveling at
650 miles per second the word Xmas isn't
actually blasphemous the letter X is a
Greek abbreviation for Christ and guess
what it's very likely that Jesus wasn't
born on December 25th 1 AD
many theologians estimate he was
actually born in September between 2 BC
and 7 BC which means the calendar as we
know it may be out by a few years
oh and Jesus was actually born in a cave
not a stable so then why do we celebrate
Christmas on December 25th there are
many theories to this but a popular
theory is that December 25th was chosen
because the winter solstice and the
ancient pagan Roman mid winter festivals
called Saturnalia and dies nutella so
listen victory took place in December
around this time and it was more
convenient to have all festivities at
the same time
there are some unusual Christmas
traditions around the world for example
in Iceland there are 13 different
centers including one called
growler here is a horrifying old woman
who kidnaps children on Christmas if
they've been naughty in India fir trees
and pine trees are extremely scarce
because of the climate
so Indians decorate banana trees and
mango trees instead in 1966 a 13 metre
tall straw goat was erected in the town
square of Gulf in Sweden but at the
stroke of midnight on Christmas Eve a
vandal burned down the goat but this
didn't dissuade the town in fact every
year since the town house we erected two
goats and every year vandals attempt to
burn it down the goat has been burned
down more than 25 times in fact it has
been burned down so often that in 1988
bookmakers began taking bets on the
goats survival and in case you were
wondering no the town doesn't want the
goat to be burned down in fact in 2001
an American tourist served jail time for
successfully doing so what you ain't
heard nothing yet
the prize for the most uncanny Christmas
traditions goes to you guessed it Japan
the Japanese are obsessed with KFC on
Christmas Day on Christmas Day people
queue outside KFC's all around the
country to get their buckets people even
order monks in advance to avoid the
queues this change tradition is a result
of a massive multi-year marketing
campaign in Japan by KFC to associate
Christmas with KFC and it worked
Christmas sponge cakes with whipped
cream strawberries and chocolate on top
are also a popular Christmas Day custom
in Japan KFC picked up on this growing
tradition and now offer a
Christmas Day menu in Japan including a
bucket of fried chicken with a cardboard
bottom that has a Christmas cake
underneath and a bottle of champagne
there are countless variations of Santa
Claus all around the world namely father
Christmas Santa Claus and Saint Nicholas
but what's the difference between them
all well they all originated from one
month Saint Nicholas st. Nicholas was a
bishop who lived in Myra in Asia Minor
which is now called Turkey around the
4th century AD he was a very wealthy man
because his parents died when he was
young and left him a lot of money he was
also very kind and had a reputation for
helping the poor there are many legends
surrounding Saint Nicholas but one
famous story tells us how one night
Saint Nicholas secretly dropped a bag of
gold down the chimney of a poor family
the bug fell into a stocking that had
been hung by the fire to dry this is
believed to be where the custom of
hanging got Christmas stockings
originated from by the 16th century the
stories about st. Nicholas had become
very unpopular but someone had to
deliver presents to children at
Christmas so various countries invented
their own mysterious gift givers the UK
came up with father Christmas in France
he was known as Pierre Noel Germany
named him Christ kind and in the early
USA he was named Kris Kringle Dutch
settlers in the USA took the stories of
st. Nicholas with them and came up with
a new name for him
Sinterklaas which turned into the now
widely adopted Santa Claus but where
does Sunter actually live
there's a lot of debate over this the UK
USA and Canada believe he lives in the
North Pole
the Norwegians believe he's in drøbak
the danes say he's actually in greenland
what the Finns are adamant he's in
doulica Lapland and Finland's tourist
board are out to prove it Santa's lap
blonde property is unimpressive 86 acres
and he has his very own managing
director private meetings can be
arranged with Santa for a hefty one
thousand three hundred and sixty dollars
each year more than 70 thousand visitors
come to doulica to visit Santa and the
post office receives over five hundred
thousand Lassiter Santa from children
all around the globe and Santa is able
to apply to about forty thousand of
these in up to twelve different
languages so does Santa really live in
Lapland
well at the end of the day every country
has its own stories and traditions
surrounding Santa Claus and it's really
up to you who you want to believe now
for the big question
did coca-cola turns Santa Claus red well
not really
the red and white coat dates back well
before cokes 30 year long
Christmas advertising campaign it's
believed the red originated from Saint
Nicholas who was the Bishop of Myra red
and white were the hues of traditional
bishops robes
the truth is Santa has been portrayed
wearing various colored robes including
both red and green for centuries in
children's literature and paintings
however Koch are largely responsible for
popularizing the jolly red image of
Santa we know today and enforcing it as
the status quo all around the globe but
getting in touch with Santa is easier
than you may think
he has a real zip code every year postal
services all over the world are flooded
with letters to Santa
the Canadian post office received so
many they set up a special zip code for
Santa it's hope hope hope you can write
a letter address to that zip code in any
language and you will receive a letter
back from Santa but where does the
tradition of Christmas trees come from
the Evergreen fir tree has been used to
celebrate both pagan and Christian
winter festivals for thousands of years
nobody is really sure when they were
first used as Christmas trees but it
probably started about a thousand years
ago in Northern Europe however many
early Christmas trees were hung upside
down from the ceiling using chains the
first documented use of a tree to
celebrate Christmas was in the town
square of Riga the capital of Latvia in
the year 1510 the money involved behind
the world's biggest holiday is
astronomical Americans alone spend over
469 billion dollars on Christmas
shopping every year the average American
spends seven hundred and seven dollars
on Christmas gifts every year but
surprisingly their only number two on
the bigger spenders list the tiny
European country of luxembourg are the
most generous christmas spenders with
each luxembourg in spending $800 on
gifts and guess what Santa Claus is the
world's richest man according to Forbes
list of the 15 richest fictional people
Santa Claus tops the list with a net
worth of infinity thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2